you
[Music]
if you haven't heard of Tidy eval I'm
about to explain it but a lot of people
have heard about it and have a certain
amount of discomfort and anxiety as
evidenced by for example these two
provocatively titled community posts and
so part of what I want to answer is like
why are we putting you through this
so what is tiny evaluation and is it
going to be bad for your health
something you might care about and I
think part of the reason that so many
people know about it but don't know it
or know about it and fear that they're
missing something or that they're behind
is this this phenomenon that I like into
when people become vegan or they start
doing crossfit they they tend to tell
you about it so when people start
learning tidy eval they tell you about
it and they blog about it and they tweet
about it and so it creates in some sense
perhaps more general awareness than is
actually necessary so I'd like to kind
of get out ahead of some of this but
first I'd like to undermine my whole
talk with a list of things that might
give you more bang bang for your buck
than learning tidy eval and this was
kind of crowd source within the tidy
verse team to describe a few things that
you probably want to learn first before
you tackle tidy eval
so being pretty comfortable writing
functions in general would be a really
sound thing to start with I think a lot
of people work in a domain like maps or
time series or text analysis where you
have some very effective tooling in your
area and getting really up to speed on
what the bleeding edges there could be
extremely fruitful you know that I'm
very into data wrangling and so I think
being comfortable with all of the
different data receptacles and R is
really rewarding especially lists and
being comfortable putting your lists
inside your data frame and this this
sting on nesting paradigm which is often
how this happens and it's uncomfortable
so you often want to get out of that
situation which is the unnecessary me
which is accurate I also think a
completely fair way to think of it as
it's a way to iterate really well in our
with sort of one common pattern and then
I think to elevate any specific set of
functions here I decided to give the
award to the scoped deep lie our verbs
are probably underutilized where you go
in and do a a mutate or something like
that very selectively like at certain
positions are at certain names but if
you've decided that indeed you may in
fact actually need tidy eval
I'd like to demystify it a bit what it
is so some people here this is more than
you needed to know or like you already
know this and you're gonna love Leah
Nell's talk and I'm kind of studying
that talked up a bit so what is tidy
eval I would call it a toolkit for meta
programming so for a code that writes
code or code that mutates code and why
is it called tidy eval so is there
something about it that is intrinsically
tidy instead of us just like putting
tidy on everything and I think there is
and it's it's to explain it would be at
a level that's not what this talk is
about but I think closures are an
example of there is actually something
intrinsically tidy about the model of
changing how evaluation works in the
tidy of our world that is like it
actually really deserves that name but
it is also true that the tidy verse
itself does a lot of meta programming
inside and therefore it requires a
certain toolkit to exist and tidy eval
powers that so it is also the pudding
tidy on everything it's both so if you
don't know what I mean by tidy eval does
a lot of meta programming but let's just
look
little bit of canonical tidy verse code
so here I'm showing working with this
Star Wars data set that comes with deep
IR I'm doing a little bit of data
wrangling with deep IR in that first
example and then I switch to a different
set of data set and show you what
ggplot2 does and the thing i talk i've
been talking a lot to Greg Wilson who
joined our studio this year and he's
really coming from Python and one of the
things we end up talking about a lot is
like what's up with all these unquoted
variable names and everything necessary
to make that happen and everything
necessary to preserve that in your own
functions so the lack of quotes around
homeworld height hi Wade color art right
class that is brought to you by all the
use of meta programming under the hood
okay and here are several equalities
that are technically not true but
they're kind of true for the duration of
my talk and they're very useful so when
I'm talking about meta programming here
which is a really general term I'm
basically talking about a more specific
term I associate with our maybe it's
used another language is called
non-standard evaluation and s/ii and
it's a term you'll see a lot especially
once you're sort of walking around in
the tidy in the tidy eval world and I'm
also gonna go even further and kind of
equate that with using unquoted variable
names which is like a further abuse of
all this but it's that's mostly what I'm
talking about here so what is
non-standard evaluation so every time we
evaluate an expression in our
environment and environment or a chain
of environment is going to be searched
for name value bindings so you've got a
name of something and you need to look
up the value currently associated with
that and so non-standard evaluation
means you've got this expression and
before you evaluate it you mess with it
perhaps you might actually edit the
expression and or write before you
evaluate it you manipulate this chain of
environments so that it's not sort of
the default
that everyone would expect and then
often you're doing both okay and and
this is what gives you uncoated variable
names and working inside the data frame
so both of those things are going on in
like every Depot our function that you
use right it's gonna put that data frame
first data mask and then you're having
these uncoated variable names so any
function that accepts an uncoated
variable name and a data frame is using
a Nessy under the hood so that means if
you want to write functions and you have
to confront that somehow and I'm going
to show you that there are different
levels of confronting that and how easy
or hard that can feel this top sentence
if you if you make it's referring to a
phrase I think was about Ruby that said
if you make everything equally easy
you're also making everything equally
hard so certain things and Ruby were
made very easy and then the bargain you
strike is you make other things hard
so the tidy verse struck this bargain in
a really really big way so if you make
the direct specification variable names
really easy like people can just type
them and they don't need to court type
quotes it makes in direct specification
harder for all of us and it turns out
indirect specification like still comes
up a lot so the two main examples here
are like what if you have variable names
stored as an object you want to drop
that in there and drive some deeply our
function or what if a user has passed a
variable name as a function argument how
do you like pass it through so these are
two pretty mundane examples of where the
design of the tidy verse makes this
harder so is this is this a problem
created by the tiny horse for itself and
the answer is no and before I worked for
our studio I was a professor and I
taught a course on applied statistics
and this example I'm about to show you
it really comes from teaching this this
course at five for five
so here are four functions in besar that
all use non-standard evaluation and
before the tidy verse existed I was
heavy user of these functions because I
liked how fluid they were I liked not
retyping my data frame name all the time
so LM subset transform and width are all
great examples where this ease of
interactive use was prioritized but the
problem is if you read the help for
subset transform or which all of them
contain almost the exact wording this is
pulled from one of them it makes it very
clear that this is a convenience
function that you are really only
supposed to be using interactively if
you're there sitting there ready to see
the errors and if you use it in a
programming context you've been warned
that it might have unanticipated
consequences and so you've been kind of
warned not to program around those
functions and I'm gonna make this
example actually more about LM so I
would teach these students how to do a
little bit of a tour angling data
visualization and so they might write a
function that fits a quadratic model and
I'm gonna use the gap minor data in a
moment so let's say we want to explain
life expectancy as a as a function of
time of the year this is super simple
model and the LM code that might do this
and then I would teach them like how do
you do this for every country in the
Gapminder data set and so they know that
they need to wrap LM in a function and
then they drop that into some sort of
iterative machine and before the tidy
verse existed we were heavy users and
teachers of the apply functions so here
I am dropping that into by and indeed it
works it goes and fits this polynomial
model to every country in the gap minor
data set and this is where I outsmarted
myself so the students were like okay
this is great I have this function
written like what if I want to do this
now for GDP per capita
instead of
life expectancy so what if I want to
sort of let Y&X be general here so you
might hope many do that that code right
there will work and it won't okay
here's examples of it not working so if
you just put those uncoated variable
names and in the usual way and you're
just like cross your fingers and hope
they get passed through you get an error
if you're like what if I apply quotes
you get a different error so it was
around this time usually in the course
where I'm like oh gosh like we need to
move on to visualization and I just I
never really answered this question
because this is what the answer would
look like so here is an example of me
improving that little function so that
you can use it in the usual way and so I
really set myself up for failure and in
some of the ways that I taught things
because I would show my students these
cool functions with non-standard
evaluation and then I would teach them
how to write functions and then I was
like but please do not combine the two
because I couldn't teach them this
toolkit but if you put yourself to that
pain you get a function that's actually
quite pleasant to use and it does work
to be dropped into by for example in
this case and so you can change the
variables you can still use expressions
like year - 1950 - so that's pretty cool
so in base our programming around these
NSC functions is possible for sure but
it's always either been explicitly
discouraged with those warning messages
or just implicitly discouraged because
it's not made to be very easy so going
back to sort of Tidy verse history I'm
been told I'm allowed to call it there
was an SEO Valera and I hear that there
was some thought of like maybe not
letting people use unquoted variable
names in the tidy verse and that was
discarded and the first thing that
really rolled out is you might remember
and they're still there these functions
like AES string instead of
yes when you have the variable name as a
character or select underscore versus
regular select so the standard
evaluation version and the non-standard
evaluation version and it just turned
out that that was pretty unpredictable
for users and I think not so fun to
maintain it's not very sustainable it's
like are you gonna create two versions
of every function and the tidy verse and
so that's doesn't feel so good so the
good news is that the tidy verse did
ultimately decide to prioritize
usability and putting the data masks on
allowing uncoated variable names
allowing you to use uncoated variables
and expressions but the bad news is it
made programming around it harder for
everyone and so the good news and the
inevitable that use is that there has to
be some sort of tool kit to use
internally to create consistency and for
other people to use so they can extend
things and that's provided by our lang
so this is a package but you may or may
not have heard of it's kind of like
vectors in the sense that ideally most
people will not have heard of our Lang
it's more of a developer focusing
package so that's where the toolkit
lives and other things live there as
well but this tidy eval toolkit does and
most people should not need to use our
Lang with their bare hands so I'm going
to close with a rapid-fire set of
scenarios so I'm gonna sort of fake what
a user might want to do and then I'm
gonna tell you how much tidy eval you
would need to know so if you want to use
existing tidy verse functions to analyze
data you do not need to know tidy eval
congratulations
continue on in your sort of blissful
existence but if you see that you have a
lot of code that looks incredibly
duplicated and there's common logic and
all that's changing is the variable that
you're doing something to you you
probably want to write a function to dry
this code out to reduce the duplication
but what if that's rap what if the
duplicated code is using dir it is still
possible that you do not actually need
to know ty Diavel and pass the dots is
the phrase I'm going to say Leonel will
show that in much greater detail and you
definitely don't need our lang I'll show
one example of this but it's really more
suited to the next talk but so if I
wanted to take a data frame in group it
by something unspecified and do a
summarize you could take dots and you
the signature of your convenience
function and pass that straight through
and you're keeping up the NSC chain you
have to you're not the weak link in the
chain but you really didn't have to do
anything explicitly and indeed that
works you could take the Star Wars data
and group by homeworld or species and it
still works again you're still in this
world where you want to write simple
functions to reduce duplication
sometimes your life is not simple enough
for pass the dots to get the job done in
which case the paradigm you'll need to
work with is using a function called n
quo to sort of capture that unquoted
thing and quote it and then at the place
you need to mention it you unquote it
with bang bang hence the really bad at
the beginning so deep lie are ggplot2
and tidy are for example all expose this
syntax to you and that's why you don't
need to know our lang
because it's really anticipated that
people may need to use these so here's
an example where I need to capture a
grouping variable and a summary variable
with this n quo bang bang pattern and
the number of arrows on the page here it
tips you off to like why the dot trick
wouldn't have worked
and again this code also works and I'm
able to change for example the variable
that I'm summarizing over and so what if
you want to make names out of user input
you have to use I asked Leah now how do
I say this
he's like we call that : equals so you
need you need the colon equals thing and
again dir ggplot2 anti dr will know
about this they will make this available
and again you do not need our Lange and
so if you're someone who wants to
compute on the expression and you want
to manipulate environments I am afraid
that you do really need to understand
ours evaluation model and how the tidy
eval toolkit manipulates it and you will
be using art Lange to do that if you're
trying to produce something with this
tidy eval feel I want to give a shout
out to a few resources that were helpful
to me as background research
I hope Thomas doesn't mind me pointing
this out but Thomas lovely wrote
something I'm not sure what he would
call it it's clearly not a paper but
this document called standard non
standard evaluation back in 2003
and it's a nice summary like where
things were in base are at that time
which was already feeling a bit of pain
about people are doing NSE different
ways and so he does her a nice survey of
the ways and I imagine this document was
meant to generate a conversation and
like move things towards doing it more
standard sort of the base our
conversation that ultimately also
happening in the tidy verse then Thomas
Mailand has a really beautiful pair of
blog posts I think on explaining scoping
rules and NSC and then Hiroaki yutani
has a beautiful talk I think on tidy
eval and in particular he has a great
example that builds to the end that
really explains why tidy eval itself is
necessary and it gets out that quality I
was hinting at earlier about there is
something about tidy eval that's
intrinsically tidy internal resources
are from from the people who bring you
tidy eval these are resources they've
written the second edition of advanced R
which is under development by Hadley has
a whole part on meta programming so
there's several chapters there
that are really useful Leonel Henry is
working on a book down site tidy of
al-qaeda verse org that's still a work
in progress to try to centralize some of
this information and put some cookbooks
and there's a great art studio community
thread where people submit wild-caught
examples and then hadley in the end I'll
tell them that they don't actually need
to use tidy eval but so it's a it's a
nice little like miniature code makeover
thread to look over all right thanks
[Music]